hi my name is Catherine Kwan and I'm a
developer advocate at Google today is
take your parents to workday parents are
going to come in for a session and we're
gonna teach them the first steps in
building an Android app we're gonna be
using a simple tool called an Android
visualizer and we're gonna show them how
they can write XML and have it appear on
a phone we hope that they can continue
by taking our course on Udacity which is
called Android for beginners and it's
aimed at people with no programming
experience my name is Tom and I am a
civil engineer and a dad
my name is Antonieta Matthews and I'm an
IT teacher I'm Marilyn Walter and I'm a
registered nurse by profession I'm Brent
Walter I'm a mortgage banker
I'm sastra Noorie I'm a retired bank
manager I am daddy like me I am a
housewife I have been using mobile has
been less tablet for the last five six
years I do not know how to build an app
but I'm having curiosity to learn
that's why how come over here as the
older generation who doesn't haven't
grown up with apps the jargon and the
lingo you hear is very intimidating but
when you actually start to get into it
it's very simple it's very logical and
once you learn the steps they follow one
after the other and so it's almost like
a cookbook recipe if you can cook
something out of a cookbook you could
write an app today we wanted to build
the help of some recipe that is snacks I
decided to do something to do with
Italian cookery and introduce three tips
I have a real world problem in trying to
get my daughter to call home and so I
would like an app that after several
days of gone by and she has not called
me she gets a reminder on her phone to
call dad we have a son who just went off
to college and he was calling me this
week asking me how to do lon which would
I'd already reviewed with him but
apparently he needed some reinforcement
so anyway that was just kind of fun to
put down different you know reminders or
things that could be in an app and it
really brought it to light for me it was
just so nice to know what everyone's
talking
about when they talk about making an app
for someone like me who's pretty much a
novice at it it was a great experience I
really enjoyed the class what would be a
good way to get in and what I recommend
coating to somebody and the best way is
just jump in and do it I am most
definitely interested in carrying on
with developing apps Android the Udacity
course look really interesting I think
it would be fun to do that and and quite
honestly doing an app like that as
something we could do together would be
would be a blast I would really enjoy
doing that as long as my ratings ten out
of ten yeah that's right you would get a
top rating for that okay hi I'm Dan
Galpin I'm a developer advocate here at
Google I help to build both Android
fundamentals and the advanced Android
class this was a great day I mean we had
an incredible number of people and and
everyone pretty much got through the
content and that was the exciting part
for me was watching people's eyes light
up who had never programmed before who
are now starting to think of themselves
as being programmers confer for the
first time and everybody dance at the
end that was really the key
you